nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman
it's another day and tragically it's
another mass shooting at least 10 people
have been killed in colorado
in a supermarket shooting as
often as the case with these incidents
the news the details are still coming in
the associated press has a good summary
so far and they write
that a shooting at a colorado
supermarket yesterday
killed 10 people including one police
officer who was the first to respond to
the scene
the suspect has been taken alive police
have not yet revealed the suspect's
name although we know it is a male
individual not too many other details
have yet been released and investigators
are sorting through
evidence this happened at the king
supers store
in boulder colorado this is um
boulder's about 25 miles i think it's
about 40-ish minutes
from denver this was the seventh
mass killing in the united states this
year we just had a shooting on march
16th
which of course left eight people dead
at
some massage businesses in the atlanta
area
in the state of georgia and
you know i i don't want to make any
jokes about this
this is insane what is going on but
one of the things that was sort of
different during the pandemic was that
the mass shootings slowed down and
i saw someone saying you can tell we're
coming out of the pandemic
because the mass shootings are
increasing and
it's it's it's not even a joke i mean
it's it's
it's sad that that's the reality the
officer who died his
51 year old eric talley who had been
with the boulder police for about
11 years he went to the store
when a call for shots fired and someone
carrying a rifle
came in and he
was killed in the line of duty the other
nine victims
uh identities as of a few hours ago when
i
prepared for this story had not yet been
released but my
instinct is that some of those names and
identities will probably
um start to be made public soon the
situation as we understand it
is that police
arrived and found some
individuals who were
it was a chaotic scene at one point we
know officers
escorted a man without a shirt and blood
running from his leg out of the store in
handcuffs
although they haven't yet even confirmed
that that's the suspect
officials have also not said whether the
suspect is the individual that was taken
to a particular hospital in boulder or
not
the hospital is not giving out any
information it's still
all very early and of course
every time that we have an incident like
this you see
all of the sort of normal and
predictable reactions from different
people
those uh on the right whose priority is
to defend
the ability and right and and legality
of having guns and having whatever guns
people want in whatever situations even
arguing that
more people armed at this incident could
have actually
prevented it from being as bad you also
have people who
understandably say this this is yet uh
you know another rifle and for all the
talk about handguns being the vast
majority of individual homicide
incidents where there are
one or two victims rifles continue
to play a prevalent and significant role
in the mass shootings and people who go
to that i mean
for me nothing really changes because of
yet another tragic incident we sort of
know
what the low-hanging fruit is around gun
safety and then we know
sort of the bigger hills to climb you
will also get people who
anytime there's a shooting and people
want to talk about gun laws will say
you know a tragedy is not the time to
politicize
uh gun control and that's like a trash
comment that comment
deserves to be thrown in in the
incinerator
and incinerated and done away with
completely if you ever want to talk
about gun safety
in close time proximity to an acute
event you're told oh it's too soon
and then if you wait you're told it's
not really an issue it's been a while
since we had the last mass shooting
they never want to talk about it and i
think it's important not to be dissuaded
uh not to be dissuaded by that we also
of course saw
i mean i'm not even going to get into it
because it would it would be the entire
show but i think many of you won't be
surprised to know
that right-wing networks including fox
news um during
like all night last night when every
other network was covering this
uh they were covering you know uh what's
going on why did joe biden
trip going up the stairs that was a big
part of hannity uh one fox show
did like a brief mention of the shooting
but the only context in which they
mentioned it was
how a colorado college basketball team
found out about the shooting shortly
before their game and they were really
affected
by the shooting during the game it's
like the trash coverage that we would
expect and that's no surprise
to anybody by tomorrow we may know more
about this as we start to learn more
about
possibly motive or other circumstances
uh we will talk about it but as usual
it doesn't have to be a shooting
motivated by
anything in particular to reinforce the
need
to be dramatically uh uh changing the
legal infrastructure around gun
ownership and again
universal background checks i'm not
saying that that's what's relevant here
but most of the country wants it and
much like with covid relief it doesn't
matter republican elected officials just
won't hear anything of
any any of it uh continues to be a
tragedy that the world looks at us and
says what
how why why why not do something
what is going on in the united states it
is a sickness that
uh disproportionately affects this
country jordan peterson has returned to
the public eye
after a very long hiatus due to as far
as i understand it
being in a detox clinic in russia in
order to get off of benzodiazepine
benzodiazepines that he became addicted
to including being in a medically
induced coma for some period of time
then peterson going from russia to
serbia for further treatment eventually
getting kovid19 but now he's back
and he's getting back to the interview
circuit and he's already saying really
dangerous things now
i'm going to talk about one of the
things he said during an interview
with brett weinstein and i know i'm
stepping into a minefield here
the tricky thing about talking about the
things jordan peterson says is that no
matter what his most devoted
followers will say david you're
misquoting him you're misunderstanding
him
so even if it appears as though jordan
peterson said something that was wrong
or wacky
or dangerous you were the one who
doesn't get it david you were
strawmanning him
but what jordan peterson said is quite
dangerous and i think it's important to
talk about it but i will admit
that in this clip we're going to look at
peterson uses sort of interchangeable
and sometimes vague terminology
so first we have to figure out what it
is that he is saying but the general
message from peterson here is
medicine may be responsible for
killing more people than the number of
people that
medicine saves uh again that's what i'm
hearing
let's listen to the clip then i suspect
if you did these statistics properly i
suspect that
that medicine independent of public
health kills more people than it saves
i suspect if you if you factor in
phenomena like the development of
superbugs in hospitals for example
that overall the net consequence of
hospitals is negative
now that's just a guess and but it's and
and it could easily be wrong
but it it also could not be wrong and
that is a good example or that's where
my thinking about what we don't know has
taken me
with regards to the critique of what we
do
the fact that it's even plausible is a
stunning
well you know medical error is the third
leading cause of death
you know and that doesn't take into
account
the generation of superbugs for example
so
there is a lot there but a key quote
here for what we're dealing with is
jordan peterson saying
i suspect that medicine independent of
public health
kills more people than it saves that's
the main point and this includes
as he says the fact that in hospitals
sometimes people get
infections and medical error and that
if you include all of that he believes
it's possible that medicine actually
kills more people than it saves
now unfortunately this is not plausible
this is a completely absurd idea and in
particular when we have nearly half the
country doubting the seriousness of
covid
because of the nonsense spread by the
right for a year and a huge contingent
of covet
anti-vaxxers that we have to contend
with this is a particularly dangerous
time to be making completely
wild implausible claims about medicine
let's take it piece by piece
first of all medicine killing more
people than it saves
is ridiculous now he says aside from
public health
so i'll exclude vaccination from this
because he's kind of saying
we're putting aside public health he's
not saying that
you know if you include public health
initiatives like clean water vaccination
he's saying we're not including that in
his calculation
um think about the sheer number of
people like think about yourself
from the time you were a little kid ear
infection
sinus infection things that before
antibiotics
would kill many people now they don't
thanks to being able
to go to a doctor be diagnosed and get
antibiotics
dentistry the number of people that used
to die because of problems that start
with the teeth
including how teeth problems create
malnutrition where you can't eat
never mind infections in the mouth
modern dentistry including fixing
cavities how many people have been saved
by that how many people are saved by
heart bypasses in the united states
each year who would otherwise die 500
000 heart bypasses in the united states
every single year
very few uh have a medical error related
deaths associated with them just to pick
i mean we could go through all day
10 000 cases of testicular cancer each
year which
medicine treats with a 95 success rate
that's hospitals
that's medicine saving people and he
actually says in the clip
you know i really don't have any idea
about this but he has such a cult of
devoted followers that now
they will take this and they will run
with it peterson
also talked about medical error
as the third leading cause of death
medical error is a problem
without a doubt but comparing it to all
the people saved by medicine
and it should also be mentioned that
medical error has been dramatically
overstated and when good studies look at
it
medical error is not nearly as bad as
some like to claim
now there is malpra malpractice there is
medical error
of course but a yale school of medicine
study found that the real number of
truly preventable deaths in the u.s in
inpatients
is about 22 000 you sometimes hear
numbers like 40
000 to 100 thousand sometimes you hear
250 000
that's the number that is sometimes used
to say it's the third leading
cause of death this study suggests that
the number of
otherwise healthy people who died just
because
of medical error could be as low as 7
100
and that the rest of the preventable
slash medical error deaths
are in people with a life expectancy of
three months
very sick people now that doesn't make
their deaths any less tragic
it doesn't mean we don't deal with
malpractice and hold people accountable
but the point is we're talking about
people who in a perfect world have three
months to live
whose care may have been mismanaged in a
way that could have robbed them of time
it's no less tragic i get it but the
idea of an epidemic
of otherwise healthy people just dying
from medical error
it's quite rare in the united states the
leading causes
of death in the united states are
mostly particular types of disease
including cancer or others
accidents including car accidents okay
this type of stuff
from jordan peterson will make some
people
more hesitant to get care to get
vaccines
and in the end peterson again admits he
actually has no idea
but he believes it's plausible it's
really not plausible
based on anything i was able to find
about it so the big news
is that jordan peterson is back
everybody uh for better or worse make of
it what you will
friday march 26th one day membership
special
we're blowing out memberships it's a
vaccination related membership special
if you would like to get a membership at
an ungodly discounted rate
get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
friday morning you'll get an email
telling you exactly
how to avail yourselves of this
immorally cheap
membership discount that we're offering
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home
i love it only took a few minutes to set
up really easy and it's been a totally
different experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much water nebia also offers a number
of shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
off all nebia products welcome back to
the show
remember that we are mostly funded by
individual memberships one of which you
can get at
joinpackman.com that also gets you the
daily
bonus show more show every day
for those who choose it sign up at
joinpacman.com
so we learned this weekend that donald
trump will be fighting back
against i guess twitter and facebook and
cancel culture i don't know by making a
triumphant return to social media
in two to three months on his own
platform maybe it will be called trump
book
or maybe it will be called twit trump
or trumpogram who knows here is
perpetual
never-ending infinity trump brown-noser
jason miller
explaining this on fox news just a
couple of days ago
donald trump obviously has been booted
off twitter and facebook and instagram
which were a great megaphone for him
does he plan
to try to get back on social media
perhaps with some new outfit
you know harry this is really
interesting the fact that the
president's been off of social media for
a while because
his press releases his statements have
actually been getting almost more play
than he ever did on twitter before
now that's completely untrue jason
miller as usual is lying
trump having the bully pulpit on twitter
dwarfed
those bizarre sometimes almost sad and
pathetic
press releases he's been putting out but
that's not the key part here
the key part is jason miller telling us
trump is launching
a social media network i'm not sure if
that's because the length of them are a
bit longer i even had
one reporter say that she thought it was
much more elegant
the way that the president was able to
communicate his thoughts and very much
looked more presidential in that longer
form
but uh i do think that we're going to
see president trump returning
to social media and probably about two
or three months here with his own
platform and this is something i think
will be the the hottest ticket in social
media it's going to completely redefine
the game
and everybody is going to be waiting and
watching to see what exactly president
trump does but it will be his own
platform
so just to follow up will this be a pra
platform that
the president the former president will
create himself we'll be working with
another company and
obviously he'll be starting from scratch
he won't start out with 88 million
twitter followers
well i can't go much further than what i
was able to just share but i can say
that it will be big once he starts
there have been a lot of high-powered
meetings he's been having at mar-a-lago
with some teams of folks who've been
coming in and i gotta tell you they've
been it's not just
one company that's approached the
president there have been numerous
companies
i think the president does know what
direction that he wants to head here
and this new platform is going to be big
and everyone wants them he's going to
bring millions and millions tens of
millions
of people to this new platform look at
the hyperbole
it will be the hottest ticket in social
media
even hotter maybe i guess than parlor
and gab and i love the reference to uh
high-powered meetings with teams of
folks
teams of folks have been flocking to
mar-a-lago
for high-powered meetings so anyway it's
very clear
that donald trump is in various ways
testing
whether he should or could successfully
run
in 2024 part of that is what donald
trump announced at that cpac speech at
the end of february that
you can donate to his pack save america
and he will play king maker don't donate
to the republican party if you donate to
the republican party
they might put money towards so-called
rhinos republicans in name only
trump doesn't like people like mitt
romney trump
if you donate to him will decide which
republicans are worthy of support
he will primary the bad republicans that
he has identified
he will support the pro-trump
republicans and as we said before
if he can do that if he can wield that
degree of power
it helps him to look stronger for 2024.
here of course
recognizing that twitter was a big part
of his winning
in 2016 in the first place being absent
on twitter now because he's banned he's
going to try to create an alternative
all with the same purpose to regain that
power and to rebuild his bully pulpit
now will it actually happen because
remember that back in
august of 2020 or july even we were just
two weeks away from getting trump's new
health care plan which he was going to
roll out it was going to be perfect it
was going to be signed into law it was
going to replace obamacare
never came out and donald trump's gone
and back in 2015 donald trump said he
would release
his tax returns and he never did so lots
of things that trump claims he will do
or others claim trump will do never end
up happening i have no idea
it may happen it may not what we can be
absolutely certain of
is that if donald trump does launch a
social media platform
it will very quickly become a central
node
of disinformation propaganda it's also
funny
to hear jason miller say trump is going
to redefine
social media it's always so endlessly
hyperbolic
it's the same thing they said about
trump's presidency now
in a sense trump redefined the
presidency
to the point of bad in showing how
corrupt a president could be
but redefining it in terms of finally
draining the swamp
and changing everything you know it okay
he was the most corrupt
administrator in the modern political
era
but that's not exactly a change i'd be
bragging about so maybe we'll see more
of the same with the social media thing
maybe it'll just never happen as so many
of the things that are promised
never do but the latest is trump will
return
with his own social media platform let
me know what you think it should be
called
i'm terrible at this stuff trumpogram
and trump book
is the only thing i could come up with
um because i'm just completely
uncreative but i know some of you will
have some better ideas
we absolutely must go over
a bizarre and embarrassing interview
given yesterday to fox news by former
president donald trump
and it was humiliating and embarrassing
not just for trump but
also for fox news which in the middle of
the interview
falsely reported the resignation of joe
biden's secretary of homeland security
just they just reported it in the middle
of the interview with trump then had to
walk it back
after trump had already reacted to it so
let's get into it donald trump kicked
the interview off
with really similar rhetoric about
immigrants to that of his infamous 2015
speech
about mexicans a lot of this vocabulary
will probably sound familiar to you
bringing the violence to our country
because many of the people coming are
not non-violent people they're violent
people many of the people coming
these countries don't send out their
finest and
in some cases i'm sure you have
wonderful fine people
but you also have criminals you have uh
murderers
you have uh sex traffickers you have a
lot of very bad people
coming into our country the theme in
this interview
was trump saying ridiculous things
with no pushback whatsoever from
interviewer harris faulkner
here's another example where again
donald trump continues to say he
actually won
not joe biden harris faulkner just
accepts it no big deal
policies and even you know i was
i mean look we won the election as far
as i'm concerned we had a great election
we got almost 75 million votes but we
were going to
uh make it even more stringent with the
understanding that we want people to
come into our country but they have to
come in legally very simple
so let me let me ask you this i i want
to get back a moment and and
revisit the covid19 because that just no
pushback at all from faulkner despite
the fact that donald trump is saying
something completely
verifiably empirically untrue she just
moves on
then donald trump makes false claims
about
joe biden's policy at the border again
no pushback from harris faulkner
whatsoever oh
i mean it was just announced they're
allowing everybody
to walk through and just come in and
they're not taking
anything they have no information about
the people and then we get to arguably
the most
surreal moment of the interview other
than when trump said
i don't know why i'm here you really
called me we'll get to that
harris faulkner interrupts and falsely
reports
live on air that the secretary of the
department of homeland security
alejandro mayorkas
has resigned trump says well i'm not
surprised to hear that because things
are so bad at the border
and then harris faulkner says oh that
didn't that actually didn't happen
take a look at this this because it's
just happened now and i want to double
check this with our producers
um the dhs secretary alejandro mayorkas
has resigned mr president i'm not
surprised
good that's a big victory for our
country hold on let me
let let me stop let me stop let me
listen to my team one more time
forgive me forgive me that has not
happened
but uh and i apologize listening to the
team
where do they even get that literal fake
news being reported live
on fox news and maybe that warrants um
more
more discussion on its own trump then
hilariously says
joe biden isn't being transparent
what do you say about the transparency
with the current
administration well there is none there
is none
remember trump promised his tax returns
six years ago
never released them trump promised to
drain the swamp he didn't
trump lied about what he privately knew
about kovid
i could go on and on and on but trump
says biden isn't being transparent and
then donald trump is asked why are you
choosing to weigh in so strongly and he
just sort of says
i don't know you guys called me really
most presidents ex-presidents like
yourself do not weigh in at this level
why did you feel like you needed to on
this issue
well you called me i didn't call you in
all fairness but the reason i weigh
in you wrote a statement last night it
was when i wrote a statement i put out a
statement
so an irritated sounding trump there
always just so
strange and then donald trump starts to
wrap up the interview by saying that
china is quote looking at woke that's
pretty unusual terminology china's
looking at woke
and then he says i don't know something
about dr seuss which nobody has ever
seen before
in order to accomplish the green new
deal nonsense
uh they're destroying it with woke when
china looks at woke and they see the
biggest problem we have is dr
seuss in the meantime they're building
factories and trying to
kill us in so many different ways they
laugh at us they think we're so
frankly they think our country is stupid
when they look at this when our
competitors look at what's going on in
our country
taking down the statues to great heroes
and so many other things
now uh i do it because i want to do
what's right
and they are destroying our country
isn't that truly something
china is going to be building factories
and trying to kill us so donald trump
trying to rehab
his greatest hits essentially while at
the same time
telling more lies mixed in
with a false resignation report from fox
news in the middle of it
having to almost immediately be walked
back i mean this is the epitome of the
trump interview
trump won't stop lying interviewer won't
question any of the lies
but reports her own literal fake news in
the middle of the interview
we'll have more on this interview
because it was so wacky and wide-ranging
uh on the david pakman show instagram
you can
find us there at david pakman show
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
today we're going to be speaking with
jonathan cohn who's a senior national
correspondent at huffpost and also
author of the book the 10-year war
obamacare and the unfinished crusade for
universal coverage
great to have you on jonathan thanks for
having me on the show
so to start with you know for for a
while the way that particularly
the right but even sometimes democrats
would talk about obamacare was this sort
of like appendage
onto what was there before which could
be
cut off and separated kind of at any
time the language of
well we can we can repeal it and we'll
put something
else in place correct me if i'm wrong
but
we seem to be getting beyond that to
where obamacare is no longer
this kind of standalone appendage to the
health care system and it's just
more part of the status quo and it's
it's
becoming more of uh the system that we
would have to modify
or work off of if we want to do further
changes is is my perception
accurate as far as that goes yeah i mean
i think just by
default almost when when you have
something that exists
for as long as the affordable care act
has existed
um uh you know when you when it
it's it's so entrenched in our system
now
that to pull it out would be very hard
um
and you know uh it's true you know
people have insurance that they rely
upon
uh their healthcare industry
uh is now sort of reoriented itself
around having this program in place
and so pulling it out now is you have to
pull out a whole bunch of wiring
that goes with it and you know it's
interesting because historically this is
one of the
uh obstacles to passing reform right
it's that the status quo is always hard
to change
well now the affordable care act you
know that's why it was hard to pass the
affordable care act that's
why it was such a fight and continued to
be such a fight
but now that's been around for 10 years
you know it's it's it's now it's part of
the status quo and it's hard to change
and i think you see that in part
by the behavior of the republicans who
don't really talk about repeal anymore
which
as you know it wasn't that long ago it
was it was all they could talk about
yeah and one sometimes i hear the
criticism
from folks who believe that the
affordable care act
doesn't go nearly far enough and i'm
under that umbrella to some degree but
but not you know there's certainly a
spectrum within that
sometimes you hear the critique that
barack obama should have started
at the position of medicare for all and
then negotiated to
something that would have been better
than what we got i don't subscribe to
that exactly because i mean he wasn't
for medicare for all it would be
unlikely to expect someone to start a
negotiation
with a position that's not even their
stated position but
i do think that maybe there would have
been a way to
to end up with a public option having
chronicled
the way that this all came together is
it unreasonable for me to think
that some other approach might have
given us a public option back in 2010.
so i wouldn't say unreasonable certainly
i mean
you know you can any critique is
reasonable and i think you know
reasonable people can debate about this
i'm i will say i'm very skeptical of
that argument though
um for two reasons so number one um
in in studying the history of healthcare
you know it it
there was a century of working on this
basically and almost
without exception it was a failure um
reforming health care is really hard
uh reforming it in you know given the
constraints of the united states
government where the senate and the
power of special interests is even
harder
the country politically was in a
different place ten years ago than it is
today i mean
i i think a lot of people who are more
progressive minded don't remember that
you know
the country the political conversation
was just a more conservative
conversation we were still in the
back end of the reagan era where
everyone was very skeptical of
government
and the only reason health care reform
got as far as it did and i talked about
this a lot in the book
is that there was a real effort for the
10 years leading
up to the affordable care act so the 10
years before the 10-year war
by democrats to really get together and
say look the only way we're going to get
through this the only way we're going to
overcome our past failures is to all get
on the same page
and and and and medicare for all was
just
not in the conversation it's not like it
was today where had been the subject of
a presidential campaign
for two consecutive uh uh elections
where you had sort of invisible
proponents who had a big grassroots
movement behind it
so you know if obama had gone in sort of
you know offering to do medicare for all
at the beginning i think just there
would have been
the whole thing would have fallen apart
um you know and in terms of getting a
public option through now obviously he
did endorse a public option he ran on a
public option it was part of his plan
um at the end of the day they took it
out and a lot of progressives felt like
he never really
fought for it uh and you know there is
something you know there's maybe
something to that i think
a lot of progress has felt like he could
have pushed harder the flip side of the
argument is the votes were not there
um in the united states senate there
were a whole group of senators
and also in the house there were some
there were some conservative democrats
although it was less of an issue there
but in the senate you had a bunch of
conservative democrats who would not
vote for it
and they had no margin for they needed
every single vote
and uh there i don't it's really hard to
imagine
uh a scenario where you could get it
through especially given how
opposed the sort of the the sort of most
conservative members of the caucus i
mean when they got to the bill and they
were getting to the end they got to 55
56 votes you know they couldn't get joe
lieberman they couldn't get
ben nelson both lieberman and nelson
were dead set against
the public option and there were others
who were not so vocal about it but were
also against it so i have a hard time
seeing how a bill passes
with a public option in it yeah i mean
that to a lesser extent we saw this with
the fifteen dollar minimum wage in the
cove in the recent covet 19 relief bill
where
there were some who were saying this is
as simple as overriding the
parliamentarian
and putting the 15 minimum wage into the
bill
but then it simply wouldn't have passed
because it doesn't it doesn't seem
democrats had the vote i mean obviously
obamacare
was was bigger and changed in a more
systemic way a lot of aspects of how the
system worked
but sometimes maybe people forget that
there's still a lot of a lot of very
centrist democrats in the in the senate
there are it's the same exact problem
today i mean you know
and it's always those you know senators
on the fringe who have the leverage
ultimately
and and they have the leverage listen
you know let's remember why they have
the leverage
i mean obviously if you if you're in a
situation where whether it's you're
going for 60 votes or 50 votes and and
you have exactly the number you need so
that's this you know let's
let's say today you have exactly 50
democrats um
you know obviously any one senator can
object and sort of hold up proceedings
and so they in theory have leverage
but at the end of the day on the
affordable care act at least what
happened was
the people who were in favor of reform
the liberals the progressives
they wanted this very badly i mean this
this this was something you know
getting universal coverage or getting
close to universal coverage it was
you know it was in their dna it's why
they got elected to congress in the
first place
and the more conservative democrats a
lot of them i mean they were in favor of
it
but you know they weren't that
passionate about it and they they would
have been okay
dropping it or at least compromising to
something much much smaller and so you
know in a game of chicken
you know who wins is the one who's
willing to kind of let it you know let
it all go and
fall off the cliff or have the crash or
whatever the the analogy is
and you know the liberal democrats in
the day weren't willing to let this
thing die
and as a result they had less leverage
there's no question that there are some
who
uh maybe understate or maybe under
understand
the the good things that came from the
affordable care act and
there's a list that probably will bring
a bell to many in my audience including
establishing exchanges
the pre-existing conditions provision
people
young adults being able to stay on their
parent insurance until age 26 and many
other things
on the other hand when you see that
premiums
even within the exchanges and me as a
self-employed person you know
i have one of those plans the the price
of these premiums is going up
in a cartoonish way that dramatically
outpaces inflation
and cost of living and all these other
things um it's it's hard to feel
as though it came close to doing nearly
enough what i'm curious about
is does it help set up whatever the next
step is going to be
like what how does it serve as a bridge
to what so many of us know
has to have more done on it or are we
really just starting fresh again
whenever
someone decides to take it up maybe
it'll be this administration
um it's a bridge and i think it's a very
big bridge um i mean i think
you you know it has put the building
blocks
in place a lot of the key building
blocks of what you know i would consider
a working universal
health care system right really so i
mean uh yeah
absolutely i mean i mean what i consider
you know how do you define universal
health care let's take a step
back i mean yeah the universal health
care system to me and i think is a sort
of generally accepted definition among
people who study this you know
everybody has insurance everybody has
good insurance so they're not
uh facing bankruptcy if they have big
medical bills they don't have to worry
they don't
care because it costs and there's some
kind of you know
uh uh principle that everybody can get
insurance regardless of pre-existing
medical condition
and then there's you know some kind of
uh control of
cost so you keep the system from
becoming too expensive now
we're not we haven't fully realized any
of those yet but what did the affordable
care act do well first thing is it for
you know it got 20 million people
insurance so right away you've closed
the gap
significantly to the number of people
who don't have insurance you've put
standards in place for what insurance
should
cover the standards aren't strong enough
but they're stronger than what was
before
right similarly there's you know if
you're buying on the exchanges there is
financial assistance there are subsidies
the problem is for a lot of people they
haven't been big enough and so people
like you are paying these crazy premiums
so how do you build on that well
actually we're actually seeing that
right now the biden administration the
democrats
with the covid bill actually took the
first step towards that notice is that
they threw a bunch more money into that
financial assistance so those premiums
will come down the out-of-pocket costs
will come down
they should probably come down further
to really get to a universal coverage
system
and by the way now you need to start
thinking about people with employer
coverage who have high premiums and high
deductibles and what are you going to do
for them
right but you know you've made progress
you've established this key
principle that everybody is entitled to
insurance regardless of pre-existing
condition
and those are two very big building
blocks of a universal coverage system so
there's more to do
yeah but you can certainly build on that
now whether
you build on that by just making the
affordable care act more generous and
opening up the exchanges to more people
or you say look what we really need is
some kind of public option that can
eventually grow
into a medicare-for-all system or we
just need to go to a medicare for all
system i mean
you can take those different paths to
universal coverage but to me at least
i feel like we've moved down that road
regardless yeah the the late oovey
reinhardt who's written about
this has your definition of of what we
mean by universal it doesn't have to be
medicare for all
and he talked extensively in his his
last book i believe it was
um about the way that those systems
could look
i guess the maybe the zoom out is
conceding all of the things you said if
we make
an obamacare's worth of progress every
11 years
we're a long time from a system that
many of us would consider to be a system
that's working really well
yeah well i would say you know i mean
that's an interesting way to put it i
haven't quite thought of it in that way
but
you know if you think of let's say let's
let's let's let's create a unit
obamacare unit yeah that's a unit of
progress
right one obamacare two obamacare we
just took an obamacare unit
and you know i'd say the 1960s we took
an obamacare size unit with medicare and
medicaid some people would argue that
was bigger
someone also was smaller but let's for
sake of argument say that was an
obamacare kind of leap so
i'm guessing maybe one or two more of
those leaps gets you there pretty much i
mean
you know we did close i mean with the
this obamacare leap cut the number of
uninsured in half basically
so i mean that's you know that's a
pretty big
jump um i mean i think the problem with
that jonathan would be
you know listen like as i'm going to
tell my audience in in our next segment
about a recent um
you know interaction with the medical
system i pay 5 20
20 a month for a silver plan i don't get
a subsidy i don't deserve a subsidy i
can afford
it that that's totally fine um but
there's a lot of people who also
are much closer to the edge on when they
get a subsidy which would who would pay
my same 520 a month
and still have a 75 copay and still have
a 2 000
lab deductible to meet it's completely
unaffordable so i feel like for them
to say simply 20 million more people
got care many of them are paying for the
premium but they can't actually afford
to use any of the care and that i think
is not in those numbers
that that is so uh you know just hey we
cut it in half
yeah but a lot of those people aren't
really using the care because they can't
afford to
sure sure so i i i the last thing i want
to do is to downplay that in any way and
i spend a lot of time in the book
talking about
you do you do and those people so i
completely agree and
and is why we have so much more to do i
would say
that it is also true that for all the
people who now have insurance that they
can't use there are a lot of people who
got better insurance and got
cheaper insurance and that also doesn't
show up in the 20 million right but
there are a lot of people who were
buying on their own who actually now are
paying less
and again i do think these enhancements
that came with the coveted relief bill
are going to make a difference because i
mean that i i don't know where you fall
on this spectrum
but one of the things you know it
basically said to everyone who's now
buying on the exchanges if you're
already buying subsidized coverage
you're going to get a bigger subsidy and
if you're one of those people who
doesn't get a subsidy you might be
eligible for one now now again
i think even when that's all done this
insurance is going to be pricey for some
people
and they're going to still be people who
pay too much and again
i don't in any way want to downplay that
or say that's not a reason that we
need to act soon but i do think you know
it
is sort of you know they're it's a tough
kind of get across especially if you're
a politician but somehow you need to get
across the idea that
we actually did accomplish a lot and we
still have
a lot to do yeah i think that that's the
best way to say it much was done
and much remains to be done um
and uh of course you know in these next
couple of years when democrats control
the white house and the senate and the
house of representatives we'll see
whether
anything uh does get done and certainly
what was in the coveted relief bill also
shouldn't shouldn't be understated
the book shows both sides and the book
is called the 10-year war
obamacare and the unfinished crusade for
universal coverage
we've been speaking with the book's
author jonathan cohn
jonathan i really appreciate your time
today thanks uh
for uh having me on the show
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them as we've already talked
about there are a number of different
people being sued by dominion voting
systems for the allegedly
libelous claims that have been made by
people like rudy giuliani and trump's
other lawyer sydney powell although it
went back and forth as to whether she
really is his lawyer or not
and now she is coming up with what i
call the tucker carlson alex jones fox
news defense which is
you can't sue me over the things i said
about you dominion
because nobody in their right mind would
believe that i was saying things that
are actually to be believed
this is actually the defense that she's
putting out there a forbes
has a very interesting report which
explains
that former trump lawyer and conspiracy
theorist sidney powell
moved to dismiss a lawsuit filed against
her by dominion voting
systems arguing that her earlier claims
that dominion was involved in an
orchestrated voter fraud effort
were so outrageous that quote reasonable
people would not accept such statements
as fact
we experienced this with tucker carlson
when
tucker was recently sued fox news
lawyers actually
argued in court people should understand
viewers should know that tucker isn't
reporting facts
he's using hyperbole and doing like an
entertainment show so you can't hold
them accountable for the things that he
says
which is a fascinating uh and of course
true defense but not at all how fox news
wants to be understood
they want to be understood as reporting
facts when it's when it's convenient
when the legal rubber hits the road all
of a sudden these shows are
entertainment this is hyperbole this is
a performance
alex jones his lawyers using the defense
in one of the many lawsuits that alex
jones the conspiracy theorist faced
saying jones is playing a character on
his show
the things he are saying are more like
an actor reading lines
you wouldn't charge an actor with sexual
assault because in character they admit
to a sexual assault
it's the same essential that they didn't
use that example but that's essentially
what they're saying
it's the same with alex jones and sydney
powell's lawyers yes
lawyers need lawyers that if maga stands
for anything it's making attorneys get
attorneys
sydney powell's lawyers argued that
her claims about dominion were quote
opinions and legal theories and not
statements meant for the public to
literally believe
and um that that she simply shouldn't be
held legally liable in this way
now what's completely pathetic and
transparent about this is that
she was saying these things as a lawyer
who was actually filing motions now as
we know
the trump campaign and administration
went back and forth
about whether sydney powell actually
represented them
trump did tweet multiple times listing
sidney powell as someone who was leading
the effort to overturn the election that
trump claimed was stolen from him
after she went cuckoo for coco puffs
during some press briefing
um meant to explain their legal strategy
the trump campaign or the trump white
house said
she has nothing to do with us but then
she was back at the white house meeting
with trump and talking about i don't
remember she was talking about martial
law or seizing voting machines or
whatever the case was
but the bottom line is that lawyers are
saying that this was just
these were just you know ideas they
weren't meant to be taken as fact
and uh she doesn't even really have
enough connection to this area of law
um and she shouldn't be held accountable
so the the lessons here are
number one they are admitting she's a
charlatan
the legal defense is based on nobody
should have believed the things that she
was saying and number two
this applies to so much of right wing
media
you know when when they get uh in
trouble for making completely dangerous
anti-medical anti-science-based
statements about coronavirus
um and the rubber meets the road legally
so to speak they say oh yeah i mean we
weren't giving medical advice this was
just like
these were just ideas and nobody should
take them seriously everybody should be
talking to
their doctor or whatever the case may be
and in fact there are
some right wing channels we were
watching a live stream
of i think it was on on right side
broadcasting
when um during cpac i think it was mike
lindell or someone else started making
bogus claims about
coronavirus and the election results
they cut away and read a statement which
was about you know everybody should we
are not endorsing any of these claims
everybody should check with their own
doctors or whatever the case may be
so they all sort of know that this is
just uh something they're doing for
ratings and to create
clicks and interest but they will
immediately abandon these positions
as soon as it gets legally hot as it is
getting now for sydney powell and we'll
just follow and see ultimately what
happens
with this lawsuit against her but she's
going for the
no one could possibly have believed the
things i was saying anyway
defense so in the past i've told stories
about how broken our health care system
is through personal experiences i've had
with the health care system of course
many of you remember the appendectomy
incident which i described in the
youtube video titled
my 27 495 appendicitis that was a doozy
back in late 2019. there was also what
we now know of as the podiatry debacle
that was earlier 2019 you can hear about
that
in the youtube video titled my eight
hundred and twenty nine dollar
ten minute long doctor's visit i have a
new one for you today this one comes to
us from the world of auto rhino
laryngology
as many of us know it uh ear nose and
throat
medicine now i'm not telling you this so
that
you as a european viewer can write to me
and say david this would have cost me
zero out of pocket in my country or
david this would have been 20 bucks in
my country
i know that i know that please don't
email me about it
okay it's a look into our health care
system i know how well yours is working
i don't need you to tell me david that
would have been free out of pocket for
me
so i as a self-employed person
get my own health insurance through what
are called
the exchanges and for years i've had
what is called a silver
level plan now the gist of how this
works is you know bronze
silver gold platinum the higher you go
the more you pay each month but in
theory the less you pay for services as
you
use them in terms of co-pays and
deductibles
so like a bronze level level plan would
be
cheaper monthly than my silver plan but
it would typically have a higher
deductible
and a higher co-pay that needs to be
met the higher deductible that needs to
be met before the insurance will cover
anything silver plans cost more
but they cover more gold and platinum
you might end up paying a thousand
dollars a month for a single person
but you might have really really cheap
or no co-pays okay
fine i've had a silver level plan for
years
and my premiums have dramatically
increased
as have my co-pays so for the same plan
over the years in 2018 i was paying
439 a month and my specialist co-pay was
40.
in 2019 it went up to 454 a month
and my co-pay went up to 50 in 2020
i was up to 478 a month and my co-pay
was up to 70 dollars and this year i am
paying
520 a month and my co-pays are up to 75
so right now i pay 520 a month that's
62.40 for the year
just for the coverage that's if i use
nothing i guess i get an annual physical
for that
right now i am paying that if i don't
avail myself
of any services but i'm aware
that for lab work like blood draws
mris cat scans i have a two thousand
dollar deductible to meet i have to pay
the first
two grand for that type of
labs and mris and that type of thing
before my insurance will cover anything
so i've been having some ear pain my
dentist thought it was caused by
clenching my jaw at night might be a tmj
type of thing but it's been going on for
a while so eventually
my doctor said go see an ent to rule out
other things so i'm thinking great
i pay 520 a month for insurance i know
my specialist
co-pay is 75 i make an appointment
i get a referral i confirm this doctor
is in my network
i'm good to go with my 75 dollars
i go last week doctor looks says
things look good let's do what's called
i just want to look
uh in your throat let's do a
laryngoscopy meaning they
put a camera into my throat through the
nose
i don't recommend it it's not fun but
okay it was medically what my my doctor
wanted to do
let's do an audiometry workup to test
your hearing and make sure you don't
have like a eustachian
tube issue i say sure now this is all
stuff that was done
in the office so when she suggests it i
say yeah let's do it i'm here
let's let's do what you want to do so
everything looks fine it's probably
tmj from clenching at night i've got a
diagnosis fantastic i pay my 75
and i go home i now get a bill
saying that this was a thousand thirty
three dollar visit
and i'm going to owe almost another 500
and i say wait wait a second how can
this be
i paid my 520 for my insurance
the doctor is in network i had a
referral i paid my co-pay i don't have a
deductible for specialists
how do i owe another five hundred
dollars well i look
closely at the bill and it says that's
right david
the office visit was billed at 420
typical for specialists you paid your 75
my insurance good for them negotiated a
discount so they add another 92 dollars
and the office visit is paid but then
here we go that camera in my throat for
thirty seconds
that's another four hundred dollars
david the audiometry
that's another hundred and forty dollars
the tympanometry which is five seconds
to
check the pressure in my ears that's
another fifty
and lo and behold that's billed like a
blood test
that's billed like an mri so even though
i'm in a room with the doctor and she
looks in my ears with one tool
and looks in my nose with another and
then puts in a camera
the camera is a completely different
type of thing
that is like lab work or an mri or blood
work
and i need to meet my 2 000 a year
deductible
which of course i haven't met because
it's march now thankfully
my insurance did me the favor of
negotiating better rates so even though
the camera normally costs 400
they've negotiated it down to 280 for me
the hearing tests they've negotiated
down to 110. so bottom line
in addition to my 75 copay
and paying 520 for a month of health
insurance i owe an additional 466.
in essence if i didn't have any
insurance
i could have said do you offer a cash
discount
i might have paid a little more for some
of these items
i probably can't negotiate as good a
rate as my insurance company can
but i would have avoided paying the 520
a month in premiums all along so
needless to say
i'm thinking about maybe i switched to
something called direct primary care
um and then a high deductible plan and
kind of self-insure
for the higher deductible it's a mess if
you're in europe
don't email me i know this would have
cost you nothing out of pocket
you don't need to make me feel any worse
but that's another bit of insight
into the american health care system
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
the eggman called in to tell us what he
thinks a
putin versus biden debate would look
like take a listen
hi dave i'll sum up a biden putin debate
yeah biden i fired people for smoking
marijuana a long time ago
putin i murdered people and put him into
gulag for smoking marijuana
dave i'm so upset about what biden is
doing and i'll tell you this
i can't wait until he's gone and kamala
harris
feels so guilty about putting so many
african-americans in prison for
marijuana that she finally
federally legalizes it i don't think
it's gonna happen until she becomes
president i hope the conspirator right
wingers are right
that biden is just holding her spot for
a little while
can you just step down already um shalom
brother
all right so the eggman very very
aggressive there and
always uh always weighing in shalom to
the eggman
on today's bonus show the latest plan
from louis de joy to keep making the
post office even worse can biden get him
out before he does it
we will also talk about a report that
the richest americans may be under
reporting their incomes by as much as
20 percent and trump was right about
something
trump predicted that news ratings would
tank if he was gone
that has happened although some of it is
just the cyclical nature of people
tuning out after
elections we will talk about corporate
media ratings on today's bonus show as
well
don't miss it join pacman.com
get instant access to the bonus show as
a david pakman show member
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using 45 percent
less water but with a stream of water
that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman